it's nothing wrong with a good cry this
is one that I had no idea about the
interest level and this is gonna be but
I kind of wanted to do it just cuz and
this is 10 movies or 10 moments in
movies more that make me cry and you'll
you'll probably you probably would have
caught on to this anyway but I'll say it
up front a big part of me crying at
movies now has happened since my kid was
born prior to that I you know sad things
would happen in movies and I would I
it's not like I was going I don't
understand why people are crying like
I'm watching and getting like oh I
totally get by that sad but it would
rarely bring me to the level of actual
tears that happens a lot more now and
know kind of illustrate why as we get
into number 10 which is a little mermaid
now this was a movie that I've loved for
a very long time this is my favorite
Disney movie growing up and but now the
end the very end just kills me and that
and that is when Ariel has her white
wedding dress on and she's on she's on
the boat she runs to the edge of the
boat and her father comes up out of the
water and she embraces him and she holds
him and she whispers in his ear
I love you daddy and that one hits me so
hard now that even I because I have the
soundtrack to this even listening to the
soundtrack the music will hit the point
that I know that that's what's going on
at that moment in the movie and I'll
still oh yeah I will get a tear no
matter what else I'm doing I like I have
to skip that track when I'm away if I'm
listening to my my music when I'm at
work cuz people would be like you okay
oh and yeah I mean it's it's pretty
obvious why that hits me in the fields
but it's for all the problems that they
had for all the fighting for all the
times he didn't understand her for all
the times that she was overly defiant
and for all that in that moment yeah
yeah that gets me
and yeah another pattern you'll notice
there's a lot of animated films on this
list cuz I don't know they tend to they
tend to get the fields that they get me
a bit better I think maybe it's cuz
animated films more often than not kind
of sneak them in rather than make big
set pieces out of them which seems to
happen in live-action more anyways this
this next one number nine from How to
Train Your Dragon is actually the one
that I understand the least why it makes
me cry but it absolutely does and again
that's the very end again I can tie it
in the into the music although unlike
Little Mermaid it's not that one was
because the moment the music reminds me
this one partially it is the music now
these the soundtracks of these movies
that first one especially I adore it's
one of my favorite soundtracks of the
last decade and there's something about
how triumphant the end of that first
movie is and to a degree that I do
honestly think that that music and then
that first movie is more triumphant than
almost any other film that I can think
of certainly any recent film because and
it's not just the standard triumph like
we did we beat the threat it is triumph
because you know yes they defeated the
threat they've overcome prejudice you
know hiccup now is gonna have to
overcome disability but we know he can
do it because we've already seen
toothless overcome disability and he
overcame it
with the help and we know hiccup will
have that help it is a triumph of a
better future encapsulated in that
moment and you know it's it's a cliche
to say the music soars but it truly
there is no other word the music kicks
in and it's soars and when I'm listening
to this again not at my desk where
people can see I just I throw my fist in
the air and bears a tear and it is just
so energizing in the best way that it
manages to get a tear out of me and
again I I don't entirely know why but it
does so it's on here let's get off of
animated films for a little bit let's
get to number eight interstellar and you
probably can guess the sea
because in addition to animation there's
a fair number of parental relationship
moments on this list so this is when
Matthew McConaughey is watching the
video messages from his kids and
watching them grow and watching them
have problems watching them become
disillusioned watching them lose faith
and not being there that's the thing I I
feel like the the pain of that moment
especially the way McConaughey played it
because he played it brilliantly it's
not just about I missed so much it's I
could have helped you know he's watching
these these video messages of his kids
and see how hard things got for them
honey and he it's just on a screen he
cannot reach out put a hand on my
shoulder he can't hug them he can't give
them any reassurance at all he just
can't and in many ways those video
messages are an encapsulation of every
way in which he could not help them and
it's it's really well done it's also the
moment that I think in some ways kind of
broke interstellar as a movie for me
because I I feel that's the emotional
climax of the film and it happens about
half way in and it never engaged me on
the same level emotionally after that
but that that scene holy cow
next up number seven Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire it's not the death of
Cedric Diggory that makes me cry because
at the moment itself is actually played
pretty quick which my memory is that it
was in the books too but the citric
degrees death didn't really do much for
me in the book it didn't impact me
greatly but in the film when they when
they when they porky back and they and
Harry and with Cedric's body they land
with that thud and everyone erupts and
Cheers
but we if the audience know this is not
a happy occasion and it's what gets me
and he even gets me a little bit talking
about it it's a combination of two
things it is Harry saying I couldn't
leave him not the hair and then citrox
dad I don't even know the actor but him
coming down and screaming that's my boy
oh my god yeah that one I I have a hard
time thinking of too many other films
that capture the moment of the pain of
finding out that your child is dead
better than that so yeah that one oh man
yeah that moment really hits me okay
let's get back to the animation and
number six ParaNorman again the ending
but this one a little bit different and
it is you know because I'm a parent but
it's not a moment between a parent and a
kid but it is a moment with a kid
because a be the ghost the witch it's
not you know getting her backstory which
was a pretty neat twist but watching
Norman interact with her and just
realizing how angry this little girl is
how much other people's hatred twisted
her and to the degree she doesn't even
fully appreciate it and he tries to make
her see what she's become and she
doesn't she doesn't want to face that
and
I kid that age shouldn't have to fail I
can't mean a kid that age shouldn't have
become something that where they need to
face what they've become so the fact
that that has to happen all and then her
how much she does not want to see
herself and remember and realize
everything because the anger is is an
anaesthetic you focus on the anger and
the hurt doesn't go away but you're
throwing out a portion of it out at
other people and rather than having it
all yourself
and Norman talking her down I love that
that's what happens that he talks her
down it's not a spell it's somebody
connecting with her which she obviously
never had in life you know after her
mother was gone and definitely didn't
have after that so just the power of
making a connection that's that's
powerful stuff and something that will
be coming up again on this list number
five V for Vendetta
this movie I really do love this movie
there's only one scene that I don't like
and I might do an epic rant about that
eventually but this is an almost perfect
movie to me I really love this movie but
the scene that obliterates me is and
it's it's practically a short film and
it's the story of the other prisoner
because because Evie you know has been
captured and she's in a Cell and she
gets little messages from cell next to
her telling of this woman telling her
story and the story of love of loss
of hate and of needing to tell it so
that somebody knows and you know the the
full details for its really going on
honestly I don't think diminish the
power of this scene because the idea
that you have to tell somebody just so
some even a stranger even someone whose
face you never see knows what you went
through what you experienced your highs
your lows somebody knows your story and
the story itself is so sad and it was at
the time it remains way more relevant
that I should at this point in time she
just wanted to live she just wanted to
love and the world of houndour said no
you are not entitled to love you're not
entitled to life and it makes me so
angry it's so sad
at the same time number four back to
animation again Moana
and another concluding moment another
moment about connection i has I've
gotten older I've really taken two films
that are able to take climax in
something other than an action scene I
still love a good action scene don't get
me wrong but if it can have something as
intense that isn't an action scene that
isn't an action resolution I really have
come to appreciate that Moana has that
so well because after all she's been
through getting to where two feet he's
supposed to be and there's nothing there
looking back and seeing
ha the lava monster the obstacle the
creature that they just had to get
around it wasn't even that they had to
defeat or kill it was just we just need
to get around this thing man what a pain
it is and realizing what she was and you
know saying let her come to me in the
ocean parts and to car uh she's her
again a bit like ParaNorman so much rage
so much anger and she just walks calmly
to it singing and singing this is not
who you are I know who you are and again
the power of making that connection you
know and reminding her you know who you
are and no one else can tell you what
you are and if you forget yourself
that's that's when things can get really
destructive and again just the strength
of that connection the strength of that
moment and her basically calming a
monster by saying I see you that yeah
like I said a lot of recurring things
going on here number three summer Wars
this I did an animation junkie on this a
long time back that back when I was
still using the green screen and long
before most folks were subscribed to me
and I kind of wish I hadn't done it back
then if I'd known the the channel was
gonna gain traction the way that it has
I would have saved it for later because
it's it's my favorite anime at present
for a lot of reasons but there is a
scene that really really gets to me
and so I figured this is one that
probably fewer people have seen so I
mean I need to give a little bit
context on this one it's a little bit of
a spoiler but it's you'll have to just
go with me on this thing so summer Wars
there's a lot going on in some rewards
but the the main thing going on is is a
family reunion for the birthday of you
know a grandmother of this matriarch of
this family and there's basically a
black sheep character who was raised by
her but it's not her biological child
and he comes back and he disrupts things
he calls her an old bat they have a very
nasty confrontation and he leaves he
storms off gets in his car gets stuck in
traffic but he's trying to leave and she
dies she dies because she's old she
overexert herself and she passes away
and his niece calls him and when he
first starts talking on the phone you
know he's just again just kind of
spitting anger you know I'm not coming
back no matter what you say I'm not
coming back you know you can you can
tell that old that crazy old bat and is
just will you just listen she's dead and
he stops dead and the look on his face
and realizing that for all the fighting
that they did there was probably
something in the back of his head that
always thought we'll we will come to
terms with each other eventually we'll
make peace with each other it'll happen
this isn't the time yet but it'll happen
and now it can't and at the realization
that he can never reconnect he can never
have a positive sense of closure with
her and the way that just breaks him in
that moment he he rushes back how that
just devastates him
upon realization upon realizing that you
know you were too busy fighting to
realize how little time you had left
that's that that one that one was tough
when I saw it for the first time and
it's become harder since my grandmother
passed away I had a much more positive
relationship with my grandmother then
these characters had like they can't
even compare but you know that that loss
in my life kind of compounds the power
of this one because prior to her passing
away if I'd done this list maybe this
one would be a little lower down it it
would still be on here open now yeah
yeah okay so top to next up the shape of
water again the the reason for bringing
me to tears in this one is seeing the
strength of the connection made between
the the lead characters because the
creeks the creature is a character it's
not really just home monster it's not
just a creature and the moment that gets
me is when she's decided she's gonna try
and help it escape and Richard Jenkins
doesn't want to do it it doesn't want to
help you know very understandably
doesn't think she should do it but she
starts signing to him and she insists
that he say back to her what she's
signing so that she knows he is hearing
him are you hearing her and and and that
he is not brushing it off and that she
has his full attention in the way that
she explains he doesn't know how I am
incomplete he only sees me he sees no
defect he sees me more completely than
anyone has ever seen me and the the
strength of a connection when someone
[Music]
thought for whatever reason that they
were never going to be fully loved that
they couldn't be that there was
something about them that
made that impossible and often that's
not even like a conscious thing you
don't sit down sit and think to yourself
no one will ever really love me on a
full level you know you don't you don't
sit down and come to that conclusion but
if person for some of us it's a thought
that's the hair it's the thought that
can permeate that you know people can't
see past something they can't see
everything that is you and you will
never connect on that level and you kind
of accept that and then when if you do
the power of that again the power of
making a connection I I adore and I
adore this movie I think when I did my
review of it I said it might be my
favorite Germanos horror movie it is I
get this point it it just it is it
doesn't have to be yours but it's it's
mine because in addition to the usual
grotesque beauty of what he makes this
just got me emotionally so hard coming
in at number one the movie that made me
realize that becoming a parent had
rendered me a complete nutter softie
because my um I I didn't catch this one
of the theatres I saw it on a home video
a little bit after it came out and my
daughter had been born and it's
wreckit-ralph and it's it's not strictly
speaking a parental own but it hits me
as a parent and it is the variate I mean
the very I mean literally the last line
of the movie where Ralph is talking
about it's basically the epilogue Ralph
is talking about how things have gotten
better you know things that things are
working out things are gonna be okay and
he says and at the beginning of the
movie had said the worst part of his day
was being lifted up to be thrown off the
building and now he says the best part
of my day is what had left me up
because when they lift me up I can see I
give Z sugar rush and I can see that kid
and the players love her even with her
faults like I knew they would
and at the end of the day if that little
kid loves me how bad can I be
and trying to say it definitely watching
it you see what happens there are a few
things more self-affirming then love and
the love of a child is it's it's just
it's that lot more and that specific
sentiment because you know I think we
all have our times where you wonder like
am i my awful what's you know yeah I
know you know we catalog our faults or
problems or failings but at the end of
the day I've got this kid who loves me
and if I can do that if I if I can have
a kid that I know is this good I think
that I'm okay I can't help be all that
bad and that was the movie that made me
realize that becoming a father really
did turn me into a complete another
softy and that's why it has to take the
number one spot so there you go 10 movie
moments that make me cry and every time
this is not a first time I saw it made
me guys this is every time in the case
of this entire list every time I see it
so yeah there we go
hope you folks enjoyed this I don't know
if it was a little too self-indulgent
but um but eh I I took all the time with
something so hope it worked for you
what is the the moment in a film or a TV
show or a book even that made you cry
the hardest if I were to reach back at
the first time I remember really
substantively crying something was
reading bridge to terabithia in fourth
grade
oh that him I wasn't expecting that one
but whether it was when you were young
when you were older an old one a new one
whatever it is whatever your thoughts
are you want to give a top ten you want
to just give a number one whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's share it let's talk about
it there's all the stuff to do you can
support me on patreon if you if you like
the show and want to help maybe make it
better well and that's you know this
time some of that's being worked on that
it's helped along by that plus there's
Twitter I got a podcast that I thought
links for all that stuff's in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]